zdf heute live herzlich willkommen wer
hat noch lust auf diese jobs
flugbegleiterin service personal an den
flughäfen
köchin oder koch in der gastronomie
handwerker pfleger reinigungs hilfen der
personalmangel ist inzwischen so groß
dass festivals abgesagt werden müssen
oder schwimmbäder früher schließen und
chaos an den flughäfen herrscht wir
schalten gleich nach düsseldorf weil
heute in nordrhein-westfalen die
sommerferien beginnen und sprechen mit
zwei experten darüber wie es so weit
kommen konnte sind sie selbst betroffen
haben sie selbst den job gewechselt oder
sogar die branche gewechselt oder sind
sie arbeitgeber arbeitgeberin und suchen
händeringend nach personal dann
schreiben sie uns gerne ihre fragen in
die kommentare oder wie immer per mail
an zdf heute.de zdf.de wenn ihr oder sie
die app nutzt wir schauen an den
flughafen nach düsseldorf wo mein
kollege thomas münden die lage im blick
hat und thomas wir können sehen es ist
eine ganze menge los dort wie es die
situation
die situation ist im endeffekt nicht
viel besser als in den tagen davor nur
dass eben heute auch in den schlangen
die sich hier durch die flughafenhalle
wenn relativ viele kinder sind das hat
man ja gestern noch nicht so es gab hier
trotzdem gestern abend um viertel nach
sieben schon rangeleien unter den
passagieren die an der
sicherheitskontrolle an standen die
wartezeiten hatten zwischen drei und
vier stunden bis sie dann endlich durch
die sicherheitskontrolle durch waren und
ans geld konnten heute abend ganz andere
ganz anderes vorgehen die
gepäckabfertigung funktioniert nicht
wirklich gut deshalb die langen
schlangen mit den großen koffern an der
sicherheitskontrolle ist es sozusagen
eigentlich noch ganz entspannt was aber
viel schlimmer ist es gibt hier 1200
passagiere von eur wings die in
insgesamt zehn flugzeugen von hier weg
fliegen sollten die waren schon durch
die sicherheitskontrollen durch standen
quasi am geld konnten ihr flugzeug schon
sehen und dann wurden diese zehn flüge
gecancelt das heißt hier sitzen jetzt
tatsächlich rund 1200 passagiere fest es
gibt heute auch keine chancen mehr hier
wegzukommen für die passagiere das heißt
es gibt zwei mitarbeiter von eur wegen
jetzt versuchen mit diesen relativ
verärgerten 1200 passagieren
klarzukommen das sind alles sachen wo
man sagen muss das hätte man absehen
können wenn das bevölkerungsreichste
bundesland in die ferien staat dann ist
das normalerweise hier schon wirklich
schlimm so muss man möchte nicht mit den
beiden euro wings mitarbeitern tauschen
gestern hat es berichte gegeben da
wurden mitarbeiter angespuckt auch auf
der anderen seite ist natürlich die wut
der reisenden zu verstehen die sich
jetzt nach zwei jahren corona urlaub
zwei jahren corona pause endlich auf
ihren auf jeden sommer urlaub freuen wir
haben von euch ein paar box tops ihr
habt mit ein paar leuten gesprochen hört
mal rein
so viel los wir kamen nicht durch die
zeichnungen an gestanden und den flug
verpasst heute morgen um halb acht hier
unser flug geht um kurz nach zwölf wir
haben jetzt zwei stunden gewartet bis
wir auch unser großen koffer abgeben
konnten wir haben ziemlich ein wohliges
gefühl wir sind mit der ganzen gruppe
von jungen menschen hier mit
beeinträchtigung und wir hoffen dass wir
heute nach mallorca fliegen können
thomas dass also die sichtweise der
reisenden und das hat er alles gründe
darüber reden wir woran es liegt hier
schreibt ein user namens leonardo die
antwort ist doch ganz einfach oder nicht
die leute wurden ausgenutzt und in der
pandemie hat es keine rücksicht gegeben
und jetzt kommt das wie ein bumerang
zurück an welchen stellen fehlt es denn
am meisten
am meisten fehlt es einfach an
sicherheitspersonal
es ist ja so dass der sicherheitsdienst
eigentlich aufgabe der bundespolizei
eben die kontrolle der leute die ins
flugzeug wollen dass sie keine
gefährlichen gegenstände bei haben das
ist eine hoheitliche aufgabe
das wurde ausgelagert und privatisiert
und an private firmen vergeben
schon vor quasi jahrzehnten das problem
dabei ist dass diese firmen unter dem
corona party unter der pandemie
natürlich besonders gelitten haben viele
dieser mitarbeiter arbeiten auf
teilzeitstellen dh sie haben einen
vertrag der ist befristet sie haben
einen vertrag der ihnen nur 20 stunden
arbeit in der woche garantiert sie
sollen aber gleichzeitig derzeit
verfügbar sein und in die lücken hüpfen
die sich dann an den sicherheits stellen
ergeben und das ist trotz der relativ
hohen stundenlöhne natürlich alles
andere als attraktiv
es gibt eine löbliche ausnahme auch das
muss man sagen der freistaat bayern hat
auch eine private gmbh die den
sicherheitsdienst leistet aber die
gehört zu 100 prozent dem land bayern
die angestellten werden nach tv.de also
nach dem tarif des öffentlichen dienstes
bezahlt und auch während der pandemie
ist bei denen niemand entlassen worden
das problem ist nämlich wenn so jemand
einmal entlassen ist dann ist in der
regel weg und bis da leute nachkommen
und bis die neu ausgebildet werden
können vergehen mindestens zehn wochen
wenn nicht noch länger das heißt all das
was man jetzt unternehmen würde wäre für
diese sommerferien egal ob hier oder in
bayern wo sie erst im august beginnen
einfach zu spät hier schreibt ein user
namens ergänzte so über youtube hier
rächt sich die weit verbreitete methode
von hire und fire die recruiter sehen in
den menschen nur ressourcen keine
existenzen laura rosinus hat mal
zusammengefasst und zusammengetragen die
datenlage wer wo wie in welchem umfang
fehlt an den flughäfen über
2000 gestrichene flüge bei der lufthansa
mitten in der hauptferienzeit der grund
personal not denn es fehlt an
fachkräften im flugverkehr genauer
gesagt
7200 das geht aus einer studie des
instituts der deutschen wirtschaft
hervor grund dafür seien die anhaltenden
nachwirkungen der korona pandemie durch
die einschränkungen wurde personal im
flugverkehr abgebaut viele beschäftigte
haben sich deswegen neu orientiert und
wollen jetzt nicht mehr zurück in ihren
job sagt die studie
besonders betroffen flugbegleiterinnen
und check-in personal hier gebe es einen
rückgang von 6.000 arbeitskräften das
macht rund 15 prozent der beschäftigten
in dem bereich aus hinzu kommt ein
mangel von 1200 fachkräfte in
technischen luftverkehrs betrieb also
flugzeugabfertiger und
bodenverkehrsdienst das problem
gleichzeitig zu den mangel gebe es keine
reserven am arbeitsmarkt um diese lücken
beim luft und bodenpersonal zu füllen
sagt das institut der deutschen
wirtschaft mit folgen für die urlauber
[Musik]
natürlich thomas sind auch viele
arbeitskräfte sauer hier schreibt ein
user botanik 97 weiß noch bei corona hat
die lufthansa leute gekündigt da
brauchen die sich doch nicht zu wundern
dass niemand für die mehr arbeiten
möchte was sagen denn die
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer
ich habe gestern mit mehreren
arbeitnehmern gesprochen die eben genau
das sagen die natürlich mit ihren
kollegen kontakt haben und sie sagen die
meisten von denen haben inzwischen einen
beruf gewundert einen job gefunden in
dem sie zwar vielleicht nicht ganz so
gut bezahlt werden den sie aber viel
besser mit ihrem leben vereinbaren
können denn natürlich ist dieses fliegen
und dieses flugbegleiter seien auch
immer mit einer großen portion an
flexibilität verbunden ich arbeite noch
bei dem privatradio der arbeitete
musikredakteur der war bis vor kurzem
flugbegleiter der hat dann sich
tatsächlich seine ausbildung besonderen
er fand dass flugbegleiter seien ganz
toll und macht jetzt musikredaktion bei
dem radio und sagt ich würde im leben
nicht mehr zurückgehen weil mir ist
wichtig dass ich abends irgendwann weiß
um fünf und sechs um 7 ich komme nach
hause und dann ist aber auch schluss und
der umgang mit den arbeitnehmern war
lange zeit eben aufgrund der
privatrechtlichen organisation nicht der
beste
thomas ich weiß nicht genau wie wie das
die gewerkschaften sehen wie wäre es
denn der blick der gewerkschaften auf
die gesamtsituation
das können wir ganz einfach klären bei
mir das überfahren der ist
gewerkschaftssekretär zuständig für die
mitarbeiter hier am flughafen katharinen
wie sehen die mitarbeiter dass die die
noch arbeiten aber auch die natürlich
gesagt haben mir reicht das ich suche
mir was anderes also sie sagen dass es
ja ein missmanagement seit wochen und
monaten wird das hier verursacht das ein
desaster mit ansage
natürlich hat corona die flughäfen hart
getroffen und die fluggastzahl waren
eingebrochen aber seit beginn der
sommerferien letztes jahr haben wir
gesehen wie schnell sich die zahl erholt
haben und da hätte man hier nach steuern
müssen das hat man versäumt und die
leidtragenden sind die beschäftigten
aber auch natürlich die fluggäste es
sind sicherlich nicht die es ist
sicherlich nicht die bundespolizei
alleine die ihren sachen
sicherheitskontrolle viel versäumt hat
auch durch dieses outsourcing was sagen
sie grundsätze zu diesem outsourced
prozess dass man das in private hände
gibt also die luftsicherheit aufgabe ist
eine hoheitliche aufgabe des staates das
ist eine anti terrormaßnahmen polizei
sprache die gehört in die hände des
staates und nicht in die hände von
gewinnorientierten privaten
sicherheitsunternehmen und das ist das
ergebnis das wir hier seit wochen und
monaten sehen es fehlt an personal
gespart um viele fluggäste zu bedienen
und das bricht dann im system in sich
zusammen und diese aufgabe gehört zurück
in die hände des staates andere
geschichte das flugpersonal das
bodenpersonal so aber auch die cruise
selber sowohl die kabine als auch die
piloten da hätte man ja jetzt auch
erwartet das sind ja hoch qualifizierte
leute die müssen doch jetzt irgendwo
sein wo sind die also ich erinnere mich
noch an die worte von
bundesarbeitsminister hrubesch israel
der gesagt hat bei corona einbruch
schmeißt die leute nicht raus wir werden
mit subventions leistungen unterstützen
man hat aber trotzdem personal abgebaut
aber nicht mehr nach gesteuert und das
erleben wir jetzt hier auch hier im
hintergrund wie viel personal fehlt die
diese anzahl an fluggästen auch bedienen
können das heißt es gibt eigentlich
keine lösung zumindest nicht für dieses
jahr also für uns ist das kind im
brunnen gefallen jetzt kann man nur noch
flickschusterei betrieben und für die
fluggäste bedeutet dieser sommer lange
lange warteschlangen und das ist ein
inakzeptabler zustand den die akteure
hier leider verbockt haben ich sage
ihnen erst mal vielen dank wir sind im
moment ja hier am düsseldorfer flughafen
aber der teil macht mir eben auch bilder
gezeigt die er überspielt bekommen hat
auf seinem handy vom kölner flughafen
und der kölner flughafen ist ja wie so
eine art gebaut und am kölner flughafen
ist die schlange der passagiere die auf
die abfertigung warten vom terminal 1
durch das ganze terminal 1 bis zum
terminal 2 und im terminal 2 noch drin
das heißt auch da reden wir
warteschlangen in einer länge die man in
dem verkehrshinweis schon in kilometern
ausdrücken müsste wenn ich das sehe und
mir vorstelle das ja der eigentliche
hauptreisetag morgen erst ist dann bin
ich schon ganz gespannt wie das hier
morgen wird das schlimme ist ich werde
morgen genau an dieser stelle stehen
weil auch ich fahre morgen in den urlaub
das wollte ich dich gerade fragen thomas
du hast gesagt du fliegst morgen selber
wie viele stunden vorher hast du denn
eingeplant da zu sein
also ich fliege um 11.20 weil ich mir
dachte hey bietet gute zeit da kann man
doch zumindest zu hause frühstücken es
gab einen hinweis der fluggesellschaft
ich möge bitte fünf stunden vorher da
sein das würde bedeuten 26 hier sein um
dann vielleicht um über 20 er
wahrscheinlich um 12 20 oder 250 bei der
zahl der abfertigungen zu fliegen das
heißt für einen ganz normalen flug auf
eine griechische insel der normalerweise
drei stunden dauert wenn man zwei
stunden vor da ist rechnet man fünf
stunden ich rechne jetzt mit zehn
stunden ich habe zum glück keine kleinen
kinder dabei
thomas wir würden dir ja am ersten
direkt dazu bleiben damit auch ja nichts
schief geht wie auch immer wir wünschen
dir einen ganz wunderbaren urlaub wohl
okay dann
wünschen dir einen wunderbaren urlaub
und danke dass du am vorabend noch alles
für uns von vor ort berichtet hast
vielen dank thomas münten und wir machen
hier im stream weiter gute reise thomas
wir machen hier im stream weiter ich
gucke nochmal hier gerade in den chat
und da fragt zum beispiel jemand fahrrad
des cam leipzig über youtube gut dass
sich keiner mehr für die pflegekräfte
interessiert das ist natürlich ein ganz
wichtiger punkt ironisch gemeint ein
ganz wichtiger punkt denn diese krise
betrifft natürlich nicht nur die
flughäfen sondern hat noch ganz andere
ausmaße betrifft die pflegebranche die
er schon vorher unter großen
personalmangel gelitten hat und betrifft
zum beispiel auch die gastronomie
deshalb freue ich mich sehr zwei weitere
gesprächspartner in diesem stream
begrüßen zu dürfen das ist zum einen
susanne grill sie ist projektmanagerin
personal bei mehreren münchner hotels
und gleichzeitig hochschullehrerin für
tourismus an der hochschule münchen
und während ich sie so vollmundig
angekündigt habe hoffe ich dass wir sie
auch gleich sehen können da ist sie
genau guten abend frau grill und nicht
nur sie ist bei uns im stream
sondern auch professor enzo weber ist
heute abend dabei vom institut für
arbeitsmarkt und berufsforschung in
nürnberg schönen guten abend an sie
beide und zuerst die frage an sie frau
grill sie haben die bilder vom flughafen
gesehen sie kennen die situation wie es
denn die situation bei ihnen im hotel
und gaststättengewerbe
endlich wir freuen uns nach corona dass
wir wieder viele buchungen haben aber es
ist genau das gleiche problem ist ein
berg rona schon etliche mitarbeiter
abgewandert und nicht weil wir so
gekündigt haben sondern weil viele
einfach gesagt haben sie können es
finanziell durch das kurzarbeitergeld
nicht mehr stemmen sie wollen auch
wieder voll arbeiten das merken wir
jetzt extrem und das ist wirklich wie so
ein boom der jetzt herrscht wir sind
froh die häuser dieses hotel ich sitze
hier grad
mehr das hauptbahnhof in einem unserer
hotels und wir sind heute völlig
ausgebucht haben aber zum beispiel nur
einen rezeptionisten an der rezeption wo
normalerweise zwei stehen aber wir
können gerade noch so die schichten
abdecken müssen dann natürlich schauen
wo wir irgendwie über die runden kommen
was heißt es dann für sie konkret machen
sie slots für die rezeption und sagen
zum beispiel man kann nur zu diesen
zeiten ankommen machen sie zimmer zu und
reduzieren da ihre kapazitäten wie gehen
sie konkret mit diesem mangel um also
das ist natürlich der worst case - wir
sind immer noch in einer
dienstleistungsbranchen ich glaube jeder
der weiß hat er eine gewisse erwartungen
und vorstellungen und das wollen wir
natürlich nicht machen gerade wir sind
hier in der stadt da erwartet man dass
man 24 stunden einchecken kann wir sind
gleich in der nähe des hauptbahnhofs wir
haben viele internationale gäste die
auch mal danach schon zum flughafen
müssen die spät ankommen als wir müssen
einfach 24 stunden geöffnet sein was
passiert wir können weniger leute nur
mehr einsetzen weil wir weniger personal
haben oder leidet natürlich die qualität
was für uns natürlich eine art oberrang
infekt hat weil das qualitätseinbußen
führen dann zu schlechten bewertungen
die letztendlich natürlich auf uns
zurückfallen und wir möchten das
natürlich nicht und das ist natürlich
schon ja eine tragische situation ich
habe schon kollegen die zum teil jetzt
zimmer sperren und nicht mehr alles
verkaufen also da geht wirklich war das
geld verloren man merkt es in der
gastronomie das eben nur mehr 45 tage
geöffnet wird das früher geschlossen
wird das zum beispiel mit dax dann auch
die restaurants geschlossen haben und
letztendlich hat man nur mehr verärgerte
gäste die sagen na ja ich habe mir das
eigentlich ein bisschen anders
vorgestellt
wenn ich hier in den chat blicke dann
sehe ich dass das flugzeug immer noch
hohe wellen schlägt klar viele sind
jetzt auf dem weg in den urlaub thomas
heinrich schreibt zum beispiel über
youtube seit 90 minuten im flieger am
gate gerade die gepäckverladung danke
meiner haut rein also schön dass wir
auch am flughafen geguckt werden und
liebe grüße an alle die jetzt in den
urlaub fliegen und hoffentlich kommen
sie bald
los ich frage weiter herrn professor
weber woher kommt das denn wie ist diese
situation entstanden wer hat wann zu
lange geschlafen wer hat vielleicht
welche arbeitnehmerinnen zu schlecht
bezahlt zu wenig respektiert zu wenig
gesehen und warum sind die leute
gegangen und wohin all ist soll man
eigentlich nur eine frage stellen das
waren jetzt ungefähr zehn aber
vielleicht können sie eine davon nach
der anderen abarbeiten
also wir haben uns das gerade wirklich
systematisch angeschaut was ist da
eigentlich in der krise passiert auf dem
arbeitsmarkt und die relativ
überraschende antwort ist nicht viel
also im deutschen arbeitsmarkt hat es in
der krise keine massenabwanderung aus
irgendwelchen branchen gegeben ganz
anders als in den usa zum beispiel diese
betritt debatte die wir da haben aber in
deutschland hat es in der krise weniger
beendete jobs gegeben und zwar deutlich
weniger beendete als vor der krise
üblich war aber wenn ich sage es war
ruhe dann heißt das auch es wurde auch
über eine sehr lange zeit sehr wenig
eingestellt und deswegen gibt es jetzt
einen sehr hohen nachholbedarf bei
einstellungen also was passiert ist ist
nicht dass da wirklich massenweise leute
gesagt haben ich habe keine lust mehr
auf meine arbeit ich gehe sondern es
wurde sehr lange nicht für ersatz
gesorgt
und das hat sich jetzt auch kumuliert
das ist in vielen branchen gleichzeitig
so alle versuchen jetzt ihr geschäft
wieder hochzufahren
und gleichzeitig auf zu machen und so
schnell das haben wir auch im beitrag
gehört so schnell gibt der arbeitsmarkt
das einfach nicht her dass innerhalb
weniger wochen wieder gerade zu richten
das heißt wir werden da das nur schritt
für schritt machen können und bis sich
die situation halbwegs normalisiert hat
werden wir wahrscheinlich bis nächstes
jahr rechnen müssen und das ist nur der
korona sondern wir haben ja eine
grundsätzliche knappheit von
arbeitskräften mittlerweile im
arbeitsmarkt denken wir an die vor
kurzer zeit da haben wir auch über
fachkräftemangel brauchen das ist ja
nicht erst jetzt ausgebrochen aber da
war es das handwerk da war es die täter
war es pflege da was erziehung und jetzt
sind es auch diese ganzen kontakt
intensiven dienstleistungsbranchen wie
solange dann wieder da
pablo sila live fast das alles was sie
gerade genannt haben noch mal zusammen
ein kleiner überblick über den
arbeitsmarkt
lange schlangen an deutschlands
flughäfen aber nicht nur hier ist die
personalknappheit zu spüren beispiel
gastgewerbe rund 60 prozent der betriebe
beklagen akuten mitarbeitermangel das
ergab eine umfrage im auftrag des
deutschen hotel und gaststättenverbandes
dehoga in der korona krise mussten sich
viele betriebe von mitarbeitern trennen
die haben sich in der zwischenzeit etwas
anderes gesucht und ersatz findet sich
kaum ein grund viele beschäftigte in
deutschland möchten weniger arbeiten und
es fehlen auszubildende beispiel
schwimmbäder der job des bademeisters
ist schlecht bezahlt wie in diesem park
in niedersachsen füllen oft freiwillige
die lücken
wir haben erfolglos ausgeschrieben haben
zum glück ehrenamtliche badeaufsicht
durch unsere ortsansässige dlrg wir
haben einen ortsverein da bin ich super
dankbar dass die uns hier auch zur seite
stehen laut einer studie für die
bertelsmann stiftung arbeiten männer im
schnitt 41 stunden in der woche wünschen
würden sie sich 37 frauen arbeiten im
durchschnitt 32 stunden und wünschen
sich 30 beide würden auch auf lohn
verzichten
hilferufe auch im bäckerhandwerk
mancherorts kann man sich inzwischen
auch per kurznachricht bewerben gebracht
hat es bislang nichts
auf online-bewerbungen sind oder
bewerbung ist eigentlich alles
aber die lösung sehe ich eigentlich
trotzdem auch nicht ich weiß nicht woher
das personal comments und ich weiß auch
nicht wo das personal irgendwo gelandet
es im bäckerhandwerk kommen neben der
geringen bezahlung noch die
frühmorgendlichen arbeitszeiten hinzu
viele haben das problem erkannt und
stellen ihre produktion auf tag arbeiten
tja da waren jetzt viele punkte drin
auch viele wünsche die arbeitnehmerinnen
und arbeitnehmer haben im frau grill
sprechen wir mal über einen was hier
einen user im chat anspricht oder eine
userin
anastasia fragt über youtube oder sagt
schlechte personalentwicklung überall in
deutschland schon seit jahren ist das
ein punkt wo man auf arbeitgeberseite an
attraktivität vielmehr noch gewinnen
kann
also sicherlich müssen auch die
arbeitgeber an sich arbeiten das ist
immer so man da nie stillstehen da hat
sicherlich die hotellerie und
gastronomie ein bisschen mehr geschlafen
wie andere branchen der bereich
digitalisierung wir müssen gewisse jobs
auch durch digitalisierung ersetzen das
kann zb ein check in automaten was dann
letztendlich zb den nachtdienst ersetzt
dass der gast sich selber einchecken
es gibt jetzt erst der automaten die
cocktail mixen aber wir müssen ja auch
aufpassen wir sind immer noch eine
dienstleistungsbranche und ich glaube es
sollte nicht das ziel sein dass wir jede
arbeitsstelle ersetzt wird und
digitalisiert auch müssen wir sicherlich
in unserer branche offener werden für
weiterbildungsmöglichkeiten flexiblere
arbeitszeiten bei home office
möglichkeiten trotzdem das muss man auch
immer wieder dazu sagen ein koch ein
niemand der im housekeeping arbeit kann
seine arbeit nicht von zu hause machen
und da es wird immer sehr die schuld am
arbeitgeber gesucht ich muss ehrlich
sagen ich gebe der politik schon auch
große schuld das sehe ich zwei große
zeiler was jahrzehntelang versäumt wurde
einerseits ist es eine falsche
bildungspolitik zu meiner zeit ist
ungefähr jeder zweite auf seinem
gymnasium gegangen habe abitur gemacht
und es war echt auch schwierig zu
studieren man musste sich das auch
selbst meistens finanzieren heute geht
jeder vierte aufs gymnasium das niveau
ist gesunken was das abitur betrifft und
wir merken das auch im studium das merke
ich auch selbst wenn ich die studierende
und berichte und mir fällt auch extrem
auf dass die studierenden nicht mehr
bereit sind neben dem studium zu
arbeiten das war vor zehn 15 jahren
völlig normal also da gebe ich an der
zeit wir haben in deutschland eine
gesellschaft werk quasi nicht aber für
machen das studiert ist nichts mehr wert
ich glaube da müssen wir wieder ein
umdenken dransetzen dass eben handwerk
mittelstand auch etwas wert ist nach der
anderen seite haben wir ein extremes
integrationsproblem schockierend
material entschuldigung darf ich sie
darf ich sie an der stelle ganz kurz
stoppen weil also damit wir an dem punkt
einfach noch bleiben weil es mich
interessieren würde was herr w was herr
professor weber dazu sagt ist das ein
punkt muss man bei der qualifizierung
auf dem arbeitsmarkt wieder ein bisschen
nachjustieren
unbedingt wir müssen natürlich dazu
sagen den akuten mangel jetzt beim
servicepersonal in der gastronomie und
abflughafen und so wird uns das nicht
bekämpfen zumal es da auch oft um kräfte
geht die ja gar keine formale
qualifikation haben aber der punkt mit
der beruflichen ausbildung der ist
absolut richtig da haben wir seit jahren
nicht erst seit kona immer weiter
zurückgehender zahlen von bewerberinnen
und bewerbern also die berufliche
ausbildung trocknet mehr und mehr aus
dabei ist das eigentlich der rückgrat
das rückgrat des deutschen arbeitsmarkt
und dementsprechend müssen wir danach
legen und in zwei richtungen denken also
einmal wirklich attraktiver werden wenn
diejenigen die auch an eine akademische
ausbildung denken würden also wirklich
klar machen dass in der beruflichen
ausbildung die kompetenzen für die
zukunft auch das arbeiten in der
digitalisierten wirtschaft auch erlangt
werden können dass das etwas modernes
ist dass es in die zukunft führt und auf
der anderen seite müssen wir aber auch
in der lage seien diejenigen in die
ausbildung zu bringen die bisher so
einen abschluss nicht schaffen oder ist
auch erst gar nicht versuchen also
niederschwellige angebote vielleicht
auch erst mal modular man kann damit man
erstmal unterrichten kann das sind die
beiden wege dabei aber auch ein klares
wort zu akademischen ausbildung wenn wir
uns die arbeitsmarkt ergebnisse von
akademikern anschauen müssen wir sagen
wir sind echt gut niedrige
arbeitslosenquoten im schnitt wirklich
hohe lebenszeit gehälter also wir können
nicht sagen akademiker würden dem
arbeitsmarkt nicht gebraucht aber wir
brauchen trotzdem eine starke berufliche
bildung nicht nur im gastronomiebereich
sondern zum beispiel auch im handwerk
werden jetzt um die ganze grüne
transformation geht solarzellen und so
weiter das ist ja auch eine
riesenaufgabe für die 400.000 gebrauchen
was ist denn aus ihrer sicht von
arbeitgeberseite zu tun bevor wir wieder
zu frau grill zurückkommen wenn ich hier
in die kommentare gucke dann ist ein
wort was ganz oft vorkommt respekt
gerade bei niedrig bezahlten jobs die
schlecht bezahlten über die
niedrigqualifizierten jobs so die sind
schlecht bezahlt die haben keine
langfristigen arbeitsverhältnisse die
sind teilweise nach einem monat kündbar
das wort gute bezahlung kommt ja aber
wie gesagt auch das wort respekt und
diese jobs attraktiver machen was es aus
ihrer sicht von arbeitgeberseite da
nötig um die leute wieder zurückzuholen
und zu binden
also muss eines klar sein und steht eine
demografische alterung bevor er mit der
verwendung der baby boomer die
irgendwann im deutschen arbeitsmarkt zu
einer schrumpfung führung wird hier sind
es im moment noch gewohnt dass die
beschäftigung geht es ja um etliche
hundert tausend zu nehmen dass wir nicht
mehr so sein können also klasse statt
masse das wird die richtung sein müssen
wir haben zum beispiel noch immer einen
sehr großen niedriglohnbereich in
deutschland trotz der gravierenden
knappheiten also dort wie gesagt hat
auch stärker auf qualifizierung setzen
die leute in bickel an den
arbeitsbedingungen arbeiten und auch bei
der arbeitszeit politik vor allem was
machen übrigens es ist nicht so dass die
heutige generation wirklich weniger
arbeiten will als früher das ist ein
gerücht das hält sich aber im recht
negativen ergebnissen nicht aber die
ansprüche sind da dass man den job er
ans eigene leben anpassen möchte also
man möchte nicht weniger arbeiten aber
anders flexibler auch das ist etwas um
wesentlich an attraktivität zu gewinnen
letzte frage an sie frau grill ist das
was was sie auch erleben dass die
ansprüche höher werden aber dass man
eben nicht sagen kann die leute wollen
weniger arbeiten sondern sie wollen das
wird ja immer so ein bisschen abwertend
auch benutzende bessere work life
balance sondern sie wollen einfach im
job vielleicht auch besser werden indem
sie privat mehr kraft schöpfen können
das kann ja auch was sein wovon
arbeitgeber am ende profitieren können
man muss das ja nicht negativ sehen
also wenn sie das wort respekt verwenden
finde ich muss man das aber auch von der
anderen seite sagen also leider machen
wir schon die erfahrung das alles mache
sehr viel nachwuchs arbeiten und das
seit vielen jahren das leider der
respekt auf der anderen seite in mir
fehlt die arbeitseinstellung
die leute sind nicht mehr so belastbar
alle stehen und dann sehr starken druck
stress ein riesenproblem deswegen wenn
man auch mehr anforderungen an
arbeitgeber stellt muss man auch auf der
anderen seite bereit sein mehr zu geben
und das kann ich nicht so beobachten und
es ist auch glaube ich die große
problematische lücke die wir haben und
wenn wir jetzt von qualifizieren und
bessere löhne sprechen muss man immer in
der hotellerie um den tourismus bedenken
wir werden immer jobs haben die man wo
es auch nicht sinn macht ins unendliche
zu qualifizieren bei der dann noch das
zimmer wer war echt noch die teller ab
natürlich muss ihr respekt sein und eine
faire bezahlung aber wenn ich jetzt
jeden weiterbilden und qualifizieren
wir haben halt nicht ich hab nicht hier
100 hotelmanager sondern ich brauche
auch leute die sozusagen diese arbeiten
erledigt es glaube ich dass ein punkt
wenn man immer spricht zb die
gewinnmarge ist nirgendwo niedriger wie
in der hotellerie sprechen hier von
ungefähr maximal 30 prozent wenn sie uns
leute sagen ja bezahlt doch die leute
besser dann muss die gesellschaft auch
herkam und bereit sein mehr für lebens
mit hotelübernachtung bezahlen wir sind
in deutschland ganz ganz weit hinten in
europa was hotelpreise zimmerpreise
betrifft und immer noch was auch
lebensmittel also preise wenn wir
natürlich das schnitzel zb investor
verkaufen und es ist eigentlich unser
größtes problem und da muss ich immer an
die gesellschaft zurückgeben ja wir
würden gerne mehr bezahlen würden merken
die leute gern ja auch in der
work-life-balance tun aber da muss ein
umdenken in der ganzen gesellschaft
stattfinden
letzte frage an sie herr professor weber
wie kommen wir jetzt raus aus der nummer
wie können wir in diesem sommer
pünktlich in urlaub fahren den
wunderschönen geputzte dekorierte und
gut ausgestattete hotels bei gutem essen
verlangen viel
es wird nur schritt für schritt gehen
wir sind in einer situation die über
eine lange krise so zustande gekommen
ist das werden wir innerhalb dieses
sommers nicht mehr komplett regeln kann
trotzdem kann man jetzt auch kurzfristig
schauen welche potenziale sind
vielleicht noch dann wenn ich dann zum
beispiel in die gastronomie schaue dann
sehe ich da geht bis 100000 minijobber
gut manche von denen wollen auch über
fünf oder acht stunden die woche
arbeiten dann hat das seine richtigkeit
und soll auch so sein aber nach
befragungsergebnissen gibt es auch sehr
viele die auch deutlich mehr stunden
arbeiten würden wenn man damals
umsteuert nicht mit soviel aushilfen
arbeitet sozialversicherungspflichtige
jobs größeres stunden volumen
nachhaltiger berufliche entwicklung die
leute auch länger an sich binden kann
dann wäre da kurzfristig auch noch was
drin oder wir haben zum beispiel trotz
der gravierenden engpässe dieser überall
sehen noch mehr als 200.000 langzeit
arbeitslose mehr als vor der krise also
auch da vielleicht der ein oder andere
mal über den alten standen springen den
menschen eine chance geben zusammen mit
der mit dem jobcenter das auch noch
unterstützen kann auch das kann sich
auch lohnen um die menschen wären
vielleicht auch relativ kurzfristig
verfügbar
sagt professor hinzu weber vielen dank
nach nürnberg und vielen dank susanne
grill auch für ihre meinung und fürs
dabei seien in diesem stream vielen dank
an sie und liebe userinnen und user
vielen dank auch an sie fürs fragen
stellen und mit kommentieren bis bald